Mipmapping looks much better, but goes to grey up the horizon. Modern GPUs can
do even better than this by using anisotropic sampling. Anisotropic means
having a property that has a different value when measured in different
directions. Sampling means retrieving some piece of information meant to
represent the whole. For example, a fragment shader will take a sample from a
textures mipmap pyramid to represent the texture's color at that pixel. Where
the word anisotropic comes into play is when we get to these pixels on the
horizon. Think about looking along one column of the checkerboard. At the
horizon a pixel may cover a large number of texels vertically, but few
horizontally. That is, the number of texels differs in different directions.
What anisotropic sampling does is take extra samples along the axis where
texels are more frequent and blends these together. These extra samples
generally give a better result, not blurring out as quickly as the mipmap does.